foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Peter Morgan I'm censored tonight
former president Trump is guilty of
sexual abuse facing an ever-growing
mountain of legal misery can anything
though Dent his popularity and should
anyone with a charge sheet like this be
allowed to run for president anyway
we'll debate that with a super pack of
unscented Stars plus as alien President
Biden plunges in the polls again I'll
talk to the Maverick Democrat
presidential candidate who says she can
beat him and become the first female
president of the United States Marianne
Williamson joins me live
and Britain prepares to host Eurovision
for the first time in 25 years I think
it's a load of old Euro trash Sharon
Osborne Louis Walsh disagree we'll argue
about it
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening from London welcome to Piers
Morgan on censored seven long years ago
the upstart Republican candidate for
president a thrusting Young Buck named
Donald J Trump said this
my people are so smart and you know what
else they say about my people the polls
they say I have the most loyal people
did you ever see that where I could
stand in the middle of Fifth Avenue and
shoot somebody and I wouldn't lose any
voters okay it's like incredible yeah
it is incredible and it's starting to
look like he was right isn't it the
charge cheat against Donald Trump is
unprecedented never in history such a
powerful politician never mind a former
president faced such a Maelstrom of
legal misery he's been indicted by a
grand jury for hush money payments to
the porn star Stormy Daniels he's
accused of pressing the secretary of
state Georgia to find eleven thousand
votes to have returned his election
defeat he could yet face charges over
his inspiring role or in the opposite of
inspiring really but the fact that he
encouraged this attack on the capital on
January 6th I know the hoarding of
classified documents at his home
Mar-A-Lago in Florida well now in a
civil case a jury says he's sexually
abused the magazine writer E Gene
Carroll in the dressing room the
department store of the 1980s and then
defamed her by calling it a hoax he's
been ordered to pay five million dollars
in Damages although he almost certainly
would appeal this was her response on
U.S television this morning
he said after the verdict and he was
still posting after midnight that he has
absolutely no idea who you are and
called The Verdict a continuation of the
greatest Witch Hunt of all time and that
you were funded by Democratic donors
what is your response to that here's the
thing here is the astonishing thing
about this win yesterday
of all the cases that this man faces all
the legal quagmires it was one well
let's think of all the prosecutors all
the special counsel all the
investigators and what happened
yesterday is one five foot two little
blonde Wiley female attorney and one 79
year old
yes five foot nine five foot nine 79
year old advice columnist and beat
Donald Trump in court
well she's right she won and did beat
Donald Trump the juror decided that the
man who became president and may well be
the next president sexually abused and
innocent woman that lied about it Trump
did not testify in the civil case but in
deposition videos seen by the jury you
pretty much nailed himself
um
I don't even know who the woman let's
say I don't know who it's Marla
you say marvelous in this photo that's
Marla yeah that's it's my wife what
she's accusing me of rape a woman that I
have no idea who she is it came out of
the blue she's accusing me of rape of
raping her
the worst thing you can do the worst
charge
and and you know it's you know it's not
true too you're a political operative
also you're just you're a disgrace but
she's accusing me and so are you of rape
and it never took place and I will tell
you I made that statement and I said
well it's Politically Incorrect she's
not my type
she's on my type he says having
mistooked the woman the abused for his
ex-wife who presumably at that point was
still very much his type but so far
Teflon Dons again showing astonishing
resistance Under Fire he remains streets
ahead in the polls to become the
Republican nominee for president
continues to describe conspiracy his
supporters continue to lap it up my
simple question is this is this the best
America can do a fading unpopular
President Biden who can barely string a
sentence together pitted against a
former president it could well be
campaigning in an ankle bracelet this is
America's Choice and America's fight to
have of course but I cared a lot about
the country I've lived and worked there
for more than 20 years and its politics
have massive implications for the rest
of the world
surely it can do better than this
well Jordan is the particular analyst
probably the best analyst of American
politics there is Frank Luntz so I'm
glad to say he's with me here in London
and across the bond Fox News contributed
to an outkick host Tommy lahren and by
Michael wolf author of The phenomenally
best selling fire and fury inside the
Trump White House okay well look great
to see you all Michael Wolff let me
start with you uh you know Trump as well
as anybody you wrote the devastating
series of books about him
um can he wriggle off all these hooks I
guess is the obvious question could you
see a pathway now for Donald Trump
to just Barrel his way once again to the
White House
well yeah yeah I mean I think that the
answer is uh um of course I mean he has
done it so many times before that it
would be actually more surprising if
this finally trips him up I mean I I got
a note from one of the the Trump Inner
Circle this morning that said we're in
unchartered territory which I think is I
think is is true uh to be found liable
for um for um sexual abuse in the middle
of a presidential campaign is um well
unprecedented but is that will this have
an effect on the campaign it will
certainly have an effect on the people
who hate Trump but the question is will
it have an effect on the people who love
Trump
um as so many things in the past uh that
we thought would have an effect have not
so it's uh it is unchartered we wait and
see yeah it is uh Tommy Lauren I want to
play a clip from Chris Christie who may
well end up running against Trump to be
president he was on Fox News Radio and
said this
you know his response yesterday to me
was ridiculous that he didn't even know
the woman I mean you know how many
coincidences are we going to have here
with Donald Trump Ryan I mean he must be
the unluckiest SOB in the world he just
has you know random people he's never
met before who are able to convince the
jury that he sexually abused them I mean
this guy it's one person after another
one woman after another the stories just
continue to pile up and I I think we all
know he's not unlucky
um that he he engaged in this kind of
conduct
all right so I mean give me some defense
for Donald Trump here
it's not a matter of being unlucky it's
a matter of the world wants to take this
man down I mean every time I hear a
charge against Donald Trump some drummed
up charge I swear my head is going to
explode they go after this man over and
over and over and over again over some
BS ridiculous charges and let's also
keep in mind that this jury did not find
him liable for rape they said that they
did not believe this woman that he raped
her but then again they're going after
him for defamation I don't know about
you pierce but if someone falsely
accuses me of rape I think that it's on
and popping you can say whatever you
want about somebody who falsely accuses
hang on yeah they didn't just find
against him for defamation they found
against a sexual assault right so he was
not found guilty of the higher charge of
rape but he was certainly found guilty
by this jury in a civil case it must be
said the different bar of course to a
criminal case but he was found guilty by
a jury of sexually assaulting this woman
yeah and again the same woman that went
on CNN and said that rape was sexy okay
I'm sorry if I have a little bit of
Suspicion here and this honestly as a
woman really bothers me because there
are people with legitimate sexual abuse
and assault and rape claims that don't
come forward for this exact reason
people that make a mockery of it like
this woman e Gene Carroll who wants her
moment in the Sun and her moment in the
spotlight they go after this man
relentlessly and then meanwhile you've
got the Biden crime family over there
amazing that we're focusing on this and
not the fact that we know now that that
the bidens were involved in a massive
bribery pay-to-play scheme the fact that
the media continually focuses on Donald
Trump and not what's actually going on
with our current sitting president to me
is an Abomination all right Franklin
um let's get to the the polling on all
this because it's really interesting
because after the indictment over the
Stormy Daniels case which I thought was
overreach frankly
um it looked to me like if you made
those payments he was doing it probably
to keep this quiet from his wife and is
that really the correct way to go go
after a a president of the United States
to take him down for that I don't think
so I think there are more important
legal issues to come but what was
extraordinary was after that indictment
is poll numbers surged and so did his
fundraising it was almost like you give
us a reason to get behind this martyr
and we're gonna do it will that happen
again now after this do you think and
you've got the exact word martyr I like
to call it it's not even
victimization it's now persecution and
Donald Trump is the perfect political
person who understands communication and
is United all these Republicans against
those who are attacking them and the Fox
News host she did it right there
but I want to bring it down a little bit
because I know what you think about
America as do I there's a reason why I'm
here
we're destroying our democracy we
actually are more Americans think our
institutions have failed more Americans
believe our elections are fraudulent
more Americans believe democracy does
not work more Americans have lost faith
and confidence in the future and most
importantly more Americans today than
ever before think their kids are going
to be worse off than they are
Pierce we're destroying
this gift that we were given it's not
entertainment for me it's not being a
pundit for me I'm watching my country
while I'm alive I'm watching my country
tear itself apart and the problem is
that Donald Trump is leading that effort
it's not about the truth to him it's and
by the way elections are less important
than the future of our democracy right
obviously we have trouble here in the in
Great Britain
but America's become the laughing stock
I mean Michael Wolff
I have to say a lot of the world is
shaking their head going you've got 320
million people in America and you have
two potentially a runoff again between
two people one of whom will be 82 if he
wins the election 86 by the end who is
already showing visible signs of
senility and the other one is already
under criminal indictment has just been
found guilty in it by a civil jury of
sexual assault as a number of other
legal threats coming down the line a lot
of people away from America scratching
their heads going how is it that it's
going to be these two
facing off to become the most powerful
person in the world
well I I hope you're not asking me to
answer that question because I have I
have no idea I mean it's it is it is it
is kind of astounding
um
um I yeah you know I mean somebody was
saying to me the other day well you know
we always love a rematch
so is is is is that part of this that we
are seeing and we now regard all of this
as as an incredible show that these are
all characters engaged in some kind of I
don't know media event
um and um and who is responsible for
that well Fox certainly has
responsibility in that
um and uh you know all other cable
channels have responsibility for that
but right now we have a debt ceiling
that we cannot solve right we have a
budgetary crisis we have a crisis in
terms of our relationship with China all
of this is having a negative impact on
actually getting things done but you
also I think you have a paralyzed
Washington in the sense that the first
thought now for any side that loses an
election is how to spend the next four
years preventing whoever wins from doing
anything so yeah and this has been going
on now for a long time and I'd look at
it and think I'm not sure how you solve
that problem so you're correct you're so
correct but then the question is what
does the media do in this process or are
they playing as as Mike Wolf says are
they playing characters in this Broadway
play CNN tonight are going to be doing
this big town hall Caitlin Collins one
of their correspondents will be
interviewing Donald Trump in front of a
lot of Republican voters apparently big
departure for CNN who are full on Trump
bashing for a number of years but you
know again you can already see a huge
Fury erupting about them even doing this
but Trump is a Bonafide candidate to be
president why shouldn't CNN do it but
already I can say this is going to play
out in a horrendously toxic way whatever
happens but some of this is our fault as
voters our fault as Citizens we seek
news that
affirms us rather than informs us we
just want to be confirmed we surround
ourselves with people who agree with us
you can't even have a political
conversation at Thanksgiving or
Christmas without interrupting so the
problem is and by the way
I actually I'm going to blame social
media more than any other Factor no
question it's a poison and it's time for
Facebook and Google and all those
companies to set down and acknowledge
the damage that's already happened and
address it let me bring tell me tell me
I mean tell me the big question for me
for the Republicans is I felt for a
while the only way Joe Biden might be
able to win in 2024 is if Donald Trump
is his opponent again because he's
beaten him once he knows he'll get the
anti-trump vote out Trump has probably
got the power to win the nomination for
the party but I'm not sure he can win
enough Independence for example to
become president why would the
Republicans willfully engage in an act
of self-harm when you've got for example
a candidate like Ron DeSantis the
Florida governor who's been very
successful he's nearly half Trump's age
he hasn't got any of the baggage I don't
really get this strategy here
well you know peers I'm sorry Michael
that was just rude Michael that was the
Tommy I'll come to you for a response to
Tommy but Tommy that one was for you can
you sure
Tommy can you hear me
I don't think she can that's the who
song we're going to fix Tommy's uh here
because I don't think she's gonna hear
me Michael you answer them
yeah you know I mean that I I think I
think what you point out is the weakness
of the situation to suddenly posit Ron
DeSantis and that's that's the only
person that that the Republicans or and
the media establishment have been able
to posit oh Ron DeSantis can run against
against him and do well but everything
that we've seen except in the local
Florida election Ron DeSantis is an
incredibly untried and weak candidate
he's a he's actually a bad retail
politician
um which is and and against Donald Trump
one of the greatest retail politicians
of all time
yeah the only the only caveat I would
put in that is that if you looked at the
recent midterms most of Trump's
endorsements lost or did badly and
DeSantis was the standout Republican
winner taking a majority of thirty or
thousands
Scott he has got the scores on the board
well in Florida but we've seen again and
again and again and again in the history
of presidential races Governors who
can't step out of their own State it's a
really it's an entirely different skill
set to deal with national media over
over local media and local media
yeah that is true let me bring in Tommy
I was going to ask you about the Santa
something but your ear fell out so we've
got your ear back so I want to ask you
about somebody else George Santos
strikes me as the only person where
Donald Trump looks at him and goes wow
now that guy that is Shameless
um I interviewed him in New York
recently and we had this Exchange
I've been a terrible liar I mean would
you be prepared to say that sure like I
said well I've been a terrible liar on
those subjects
I've been a terrible liar to George
Sanders well he's now been arrested for
being a terrible liar and he says I
think 13 charges for his lies but he
says tonight I'm not going to resign he
intends to return to Congress to vote
tomorrow and intends to run for
re-election how is America again I ask
you as a nation you're speaking of your
country here how can someone like George
Santos who literally lies about whether
the sky is blue how can he still be
operating in Congress
well again because I am a conservative
and a republican I don't stand up for
people just because they are a
conservative or republican so I'm not
going to stand up for George Santos I'm
not going to defend him right I think we
can do much better as a Republican party
as conservatives but I do find it
incredibly interesting Piers that the
rest of the mainstream media chose to
run with the George Santos story today
which impacts very few people when you
really look at it instead of running
with James Comer and health house
oversight over the Biden crime family
which I've been trying to address
because we could have potentially the
then vice president current president
taking money from foreign entities like
China in the millions of dollars over a
span of several years but yet we're
talking about George Santos I'm not
defending the man but my God you've got
a man sitting in the White House who has
not been held accountable for what his
family has done what his son has done I
really wish someone would talk about
that certainly has implications for our
entirety of our national security right
and certainly Frank that's just funny I
mean that there is a double stand about
the way Biden is treated by the media
because all the media do skewed to the
left and I do think if it was the Trump
family that had this kind of murky stuff
going on with all these payments coming
into the family from all these uh
foreign adversaries in many cases
they'll be all hell would be breaking
loose what so I go back to your original
point is this the best we can do and
that the ad that's going to kill Donald
Trump in the end is going to be a
middle-aged woman looking at her
daughter who's turning 18 and asking her
is this the person you're proud of is
this the person you find as a role model
is this the best person we can put up
for president of the United States it's
going to be asked as a question this is
not about entertainment am I concerned
in this whole conversation
is that we're trying to score political
points and I mean this you you know me
this is not about political points at
some point you break your democracy at
some point the public lose well I do
think your point about social media I do
think it's got so tribal on social media
facts no longer matter all that matters
is getting on your tribe side and
agreeing with whatever the tribe has
decided is the agreed line and facts are
getting disintegrated I've got to leave
it I could talk about this all day long
and it's great to have you here Frank
please come back soon Michael thank you
very much over there across the pond and
thank you Tommy it's going to be
fascinating to watch how this all plays
out but again I asked the question I
asked at the start really America this
is the best you can do come on says that
next she's Oprah Winfrey's former
spiritual advisor who's making a bid to
unseat Joe Biden as president I'll talk
live to Marianne Williamson presidential
candidate is she a better option to be
president of the United States well
we'll find out
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage stretching it you
can say whatever gender you are for your
sex your male or your female all right
JJ plus he become fabulous but Rishi
sooner and sets out this five-point plan
what has it achieved so far nothing when
we say believe women take them at their
word I'm sick of apologies
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
dearly beloved let us bright so careful
we've been praying too exactly it's just
like some kind of Submarine prime
minister you're making the case here now
a MILF stands for mother I'd like to I'm
not going to say the next word
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
could you keep quiet I'm trying to read
the book
[Music]
welcome back to peers organization she's
the self-help author and Democratic
presidential candidate who once said she
would harness love to defeat Donald
Trump she believes the power of the Mind
may have prevented a hurricane hitting
the United States in 2019 and she once
wrote The Sickness doesn't exist in
diseases like cancer and AIDS and other
physical illnesses are physical
manifestations of a psychic scream now
some of that she's walked back with a
history of saying things that many May
deem quirky at best does Marianne
Williamson really believe she has a shot
of becoming the first female president
of the United States well let's find out
she joins me now Mario listen great to
have you on the program
thank you so much so don't want to start
with some of those things that you've
said in the past I know you've walked
some of them back but when you run any
of them well you I think you did when
you talked about you don't take any of
it back
it's not about walking them back it's
about pointing out how disconnected they
are from the context in which any of
those things were said I never said that
the power of the Mind these are all
misrepresentations and
mischaracterizations of what I've said
if you say I have to walk them back it's
as though I'm supposed to admit that I
said something completely ridiculous
nothing that I said within the context
that I said it was ridiculous at all
that's all would you would you say you
regret any of those things that we
referenced not if you look at the
context in which they were spoken no I
you know no I shouldn't apologize for
the fact that there is now an
understanding of a mind-body connection
anybody in any kind of a
psychotherapeutic situation might say oh
I'm in such pain it feels like my body
is screaming listen I have osteoporosis
my mother died of diabetes my sister
died of breast cancer my father died of
colon cancer I have spent most of my
career being of service to people with
AIDS and other critical illnesses no one
needs to school me on the reality of
illnesses and it's and its ravages I am
not a woman who doesn't understand those
things you are a woman and if you were
to win you would become the first female
president of the United States and that
does beg the question the burning
question one that has tripped up so many
famous people in the world of politics
around the world has cost people their
jobs so let me ask you straightforwardly
what is a woman
what is a woman well a woman if you look
at it only biologically you know I wrote
a book called A Woman's Worth I am a
woman who was born into a woman's body I
think of myself as a woman but it's a
different it's it's a different world
today people can Define their sex their
sexuality binary non-binary however they
want I just know what I am as a woman so
I'm not going to get trapped into any of
that you know we live in a free society
and in a free Society people can
identify however they wish to identify
do whatever they do as long as it
doesn't hurt anyone else and I have no
problem when it does hurt for example
female
Sports people who are suddenly seeing
themselves come up against trans women
who might be six foot four inches tall
and a powering past them in swimming
pools that does do genuine harm what's
your view about that issue
that is a complicated subject absolutely
but there are ways through muscle mass
through hormones through Chemical
Testing there are ways to to determine
you can't think no as a as a female
candidate to be president you cannot
surely think it is remotely fair for
Trans athletes I've got nothing against
trans people I've always supported their
rights to fairness and equality I just
feel that this is completely unfair and
trans athletes should simply not be
allowed to to compete against biological
females and
those situations once again they're
complicated they're not all the same
officials it is actually because there
are some situations where it may be what
you just said other situations where it
may not be you know it's important that
we protect the rights of the minority
it's also important that we protect
protect the rights of the majority so
those things should be determined
according to factors that are uh that
are agreed upon by the sports officials
and all of the people seeking to be part
of those races uh should be protected
their rights should be protected and
honored what would be the first thing
you'd do as president if you won
one of the first things I would do is
determine that there would be an audit
for the Pentagon every Sunday every cent
that we spend there I would cancel all
contracts where the United States
government has contracts with union
busting companies I would deschedule
marijuana from a schedule one drug I
would bring together a group to have a
very serious conversation about how we
were going to get to Universal Health
Care and I would also use the marching
rights that are part of the by Dole Act
of 1980 by which pharmaceutical
companies are told that if you developed
a drug with even one dollar of taxpayer
money which means most drugs in the
United States that the government has
the right to lower those prices I would
bring together a group of leaders who
were the experts on childhood everything
having to do with the neurophysiology of
children
neuropsychology the the needs of
children in terms of health in terms of
Education everything that it would take
to have the greatest experts on
childhood because I want to develop a
Department of Children and Youth I want
a massive transfer of resources into the
lives of children 10 years and younger
okay
I'm going to run over all time but okay
that all sounds very laudable as a as a
and you rattle them off you've obviously
thought about it a lot which is good
what would you do for example as
commander-in-chief if China invaded
Taiwan
that's a very very difficult one that's
a very very difficult one and hopefully
hopefully if I'm the day I'm president
China will not have invaded Taiwan I
will certainly not poke the bear I would
certainly try to walk back any of this
almost Cold War type of conversation
that is happening too much between the
United States what if you were
commander-in-chief and they literally as
many people think is highly likely in
whoever is the next president in that
term of office if they did invade Taiwan
Joe Biden has said he would be there to
help would you
what did you say that Joe Biden has said
he said that he would help the Taiwanese
if that happened well there are
different ways there are different ways
to help the Taiwanese and I believe that
we're trying to help them right now and
one of the ways that we're also trying
to help the Taiwanese is is to build
better relationships with China so that
we can be more on a road towards healthy
collaboration which we will need not
only economically but in order to deal
with the climate crisis in the years
ahead so let's right now work on where
we are let's not poke the bear let's
take the temperature down let's think in
terms of of China not as an enemy but as
a collaborator hopefully someone that we
can compete with in a healthy way
well I say it was a great respect but
people will say that's very naive that
we've just you know if you did the
attitude with say Vladimir Putin that's
not going to stop him invading countries
and people look to America for better or
worse as the global policeman and if you
want to run the country you want to be
the boss you're going to face some very
tough decisions about what you do when
the bears actually go and do bad stuff
thank you Paris I understand what the
role of the commander-in-chief of the
United States is but there was nothing
naive at all about what I just said
about China and the last thing I'm not
naive about is Vladimir Putin Joe
bidener said he won't debate other
Democrat candidates in the primary
season many people think that's just
cowardly what's your view
of course he should debate us there are
three candidates for this nomination
there is not an enthusiasm in this
country as you were mentioning earlier
there is not an enthusiasm for a trump
Biden rematch the majority of people
have said that they wish the president
would not run again if the American
people hear his agenda for the next four
years and they are hear my agenda for
the next four years and the agenda of
anyone else who is running and they say
through their votes on a Democratic
primary yes I think Joe Biden is the
best candidate to win in 2024 and the
best leader for the next four years then
God bless him he should be the one but
the idea that the DNC and the Democratic
Elite establishment can just shoehorn
him into the nomination is undemocratic
you if you have a party which we do that
likes to think of itself as a champion
of democracy we should not be so wary of
democracy
it is important that the president
debate me I completely agree
um I suspect he's quite afraid of
debating you actually
um
what do you make of this issue of the
Biden family and all this foreign money
from adversaries which appears to have
been pouring into their coffers
well you know it appears to be we don't
know yet the facts aren't all out this
is we have rules of due process in this
country and no one whether it's Donald
Trump or uh President Biden should be
above the law we'll see what happens but
no matter what happens this is certainly
a shadow on his candidacy and one more
factor for people to think about in
terms of a president whose approval
ratings are already very low so there's
Hunter Biden is not his father we don't
know we don't we don't know anything yet
um but yeah I mean this is not great
going into a presidential uh
presidential race all the more reason
why the President should be debating me
and anyone else who is running so that
we can present to the American people
who get lost in all this this is what is
so wrong you know as you were speaking
about earlier it's like a circus of smut
and a racehorse and and gossip we need
to think about the American people who
are lost in all this the American people
one in four of whom have medical debt 18
million of whom cannot afford to pay the
the pay in order to fulfill the
prescriptions that their doctors give
them half of our seniors live on less
than twenty five thousand dollars a year
we have a third of our workers who live
on less than fifteen dollars an hour and
cannot even pay the uh pay for a place
to live these are the people who are
looking at all of these institutions and
saying you're failing us you're not
doing anything for me and that's what I
want to talk about the final question in
this country no question should somebody
who's just been found guilty by a jury
of sexually abusing a woman
should that person be allowed to run for
president
everybody needs to vote for well right
now they can legally so every voter has
to choose for themselves but I'll tell
you something this is not about listen
people who are total Trump supporters
like the person that you had on earlier
she doesn't care they're not going to
care that's not what's going to lose for
the Democrats in 2024. the power of
trump is not what's going to lose for
the Democrats in 2024. what could lose
for us however is droves of people
staying home particularly young people
particularly young people who are not
going to go to war for a president who
approved the willow project and has
given more oil drilling permits than
even Trump did and who do not see in any
way regarding their health care
regarding their capacity to go to
college regarding these college loan
debts that are tackling them they don't
look at the Democratic party and feel
they have my back either no I think
that's what is dangerous for the
Democratic party in 2024 all the people
who might be staying home unless we
present them a genuine opportunity a
genuine alternate of economic reform and
a whole new face and obviously I think
that phrase should be obviously you
think that face should be you and you
put your case very compellingly and it's
great to have you on Piers Morgan on
censored thank you very much thank you
getting very interesting that race in
America just on the Democrat side with
Robert F Kennedy Jr and now Marianne
Williamson both polling surprisingly
strongly against Joe Biden may not be a
given that he ends up being the
Democratic candidate that would be a
bombshell well my interview with
Cristiano Ronaldo has been nominated for
another award you can vote for the
interview of the year but I've also been
nominated for presenter of the year at
the trick Awards so go to
www.trick.org dot UK and cast a million
votes so we can expand our trophy
cabinet
and remember with every vote another
snowflake somewhere melts
uncensored next a global audience of
more than 160 million were tuned into
Eurovision this weekend I will not be
one of them because I think it's a load
of old Balderdash but Louis Walsh and
Sharon I was born gonna try and persuade
me why I'm wrong this is not going to go
well this segment
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
plan what has it achieved so far nothing
when we say believe women take them at
their word I'm sick of apology
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
very beloved and that's a Sprite they're
careful
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now
a MILF stands for mother I'd like to I'm
not going to say the next word
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read
the book
[Music]
this is talk TV
we'll take a good long look at our
Gallery there because you won't be
seeing any of them again
um welcome back to Piers Morgan
uncensored I am remain The only voice of
Common Sense here because Eurovision
returned to the UK this week after
25-year absence supposed to be of course
in Ukraine who won it last time but
obviously Ukraine can't host it so
Liverpool has the dubious honor of being
host City uh and that's fine and
everyone I know seems to be wildly
excited about this apart from me because
I think Eurovision is a stain on
Humanity ah
now the first of two semi-finals was
affected on audiences last night head of
the Grand Final on Saturday fancy
Eurovision is a world-class Festival of
the Arts an exhibition of the best of
pop music and offer Recollections may
vary take a look at this
[Music]
come on
lose
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]
that last step we're called we are the
winners from Lithuania the one thing
lithuanians never won is enemy
um unbelievable I'm gonna bring in now
Sharon Osborne and Louis ball Sharon's
with me Louise wherever Louis is uh the
parents are going to try and he's an arm
of course he is they're going to try and
persuade me that this ludicrous fast is
actually a credible tournament Louis you
go first try come on
I say it's awesome listen I watched the
semi-final last night I know you do but
I think it's brilliant fun I watch it
every single year there are some really
good songs you played all the bad ones
but there's some Abba came from us
Celine Dion Johnny Logan so many great
people it's light entertainment at its
best Pierce and you may not like it but
I love it I think it's honestly sure I
bet Sharon well the thing is it doesn't
surprise me you like it because when we
did America's Got Talent together you
always put the Nutty acts like that
through and it was down to me on behalf
of the Grateful American people to buzz
them off you love this crap
I do it's not crap it is troll because
there's no cultural it is it's very
interesting to see all these different
cultures and what they consider to be
entertainment and it's very interesting
look a little bit you know the worst
thing about it and I'm gonna say this is
somebody who went to Ukraine to
interview president zielinski and his
wife and I've obviously done a lot of
stuff about the Ukraine war I really
didn't like Ukraine winning it last year
simply because the country's at War and
I don't and I'm sure they're gonna
probably win it again this year for the
same reason the moment any competition
to me goes into what I call just
transparent virtue signaling they
weren't the best act they all know them
then it's not a competition
it's something else it's like it's
people just ticking boxes no it's people
that like other people peers and try and
understand that you know the worst thing
Louie I I when I went to Ukraine I came
through the train station to go back to
Poland and the train station managing
gave me the hat that the winner of the
Ukraine that that hat he gave it to the
train station guy in Kiev and signed it
and he and the guy gave it to me uh and
obviously I was the last thing I wanted
to take I had to pretend to be happy you
should have put it on for a picture
I love Ukraine I love ukrainians I want
them to win this War I don't want to see
them keep winning competitions simply
because they're a war it's ridiculous
they only won last year I mean I've
voted for them maybe 10 times last year
I wanted them to win because because
your life is pretty good
yes okay let's pairs it was a good song
we listened to the songs Sharon and I
are in the music business
it wasn't a good song it was
something
I'm too sad but when was that 1970 right
Celine Dion Johnny Logan box Fizz loads
of people I watched last night there's
some amazing things
I thought I thought that Switzerland was
good did you like Switzerland Louis
I did but I love Finland I know he's a
bit crazy but I loved it I also loved
Israel I thought it was she's good
my other problem with it is it's a
complete Carver where all the countries
basically look after their mates none of
it none of the Voting is genuine the
often take the best song and obliterates
it because it's not from a country
that's part of that impact peers you are
wrong the best song Always Wins always
yeah but the bar is unbelievable a the
bar is unbelievably low for that title
and be the best song never wins but it's
about entertainment peers it's about
personality
presentation all of that well let's see
this this is the UK entry this year have
a listen to some of this
yeah I know
[Music]
[Applause]
please
stop that look this is my point this is
my point about that that is that you
hear that in every Euro trash disco at
three in the morning when they want
people to leave they turn on that kind
of stuff when they want to kick people
out it's not it represents the use of
today yes there's not that person under
50 who would listen to that and not
think it's horrified you're wrong
peers in Lithuania at three in the
morning that's what that's for no and
the idea that you too you do actually
know your music this is what offends me
you do married to one of the greatest
rock stars in entertainment weaned on
rock music father one of the great Rock
managers and you Louis Awards produce
some of the great pop bands of all time
the fact that you have straight faces
because it's as you try and persuade me
that this garbage is serious music I
love it
I do
are you both gonna watch the whole thing
absolutely you're gonna watch it
absolutely Lily what about I'm not
getting through
no it wasn't great it wasn't great it
wasn't great oh really Eurovision that
wasn't great
yeah
killers there are some great songs
neither of you believe me
to annoy people like me whoever really
gifted musically no no it's not it's
about it makes people happy this is why
I had to be the lead judge on America's
Got Talent because Sharon would go nuts
and put these sort of Acts through and I
would have to then save the night
pears does a massive Market
150 million people can't be wrong they
can and they are it the whole thing is a
completely nasty it's a travestyles
BBC have done a great job
it's amazing amazing
it's not just the songs we watch for the
clothes the dancing all the outrageous
differences all right yes just play me a
little bit we played at the start please
this is this is closed it's the music
it's the whole the whole ensemble let's
remind ourselves of that it's everything
here we go
foreign
[Music]
it is utter nonsense I will not be
anywhere near a TV on Saturday night yes
Louis lovely to see you though and
Sharon lovely to see you always a
pleasure
I know that off camera you'll both said
to me you know what you're right but
that's what normally happens that's a
problem
I keep it real not this time uncensored
next to me should straight actors be
allowed to to play gay roles well
apparently not one lgbtq plus whatever
the other digits are star things no you
can't have that you can only be gay now
to play gay role to which I say great in
that case you can only be straight to
play straight rolls guess what that
debate is going to disappear very
quickly if the rules work both ways
we'll debate this after the break
foreign
[Music]
sets out this five-point plan what has
it achieved so far nothing when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apology
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
really beloved let us Pride they're
careful who are you trying to exactly
it's just like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word pop the kettle on this is the royal
tea did you keep quiet I'm trying to
read a book
[Music]
we're coming up on the tour tonight our
Sharon will be jumping back into this
studio to join us and we'll be
discussing the illegal migration Bill
the Archbishop Canterbury Justin will be
slates it in the House of Lords and NHS
Staffing plans are under scrutiny as the
health service plans for school leavers
to work on Hospital Awards without
having to go to university first and Tom
Hanks vows to boycott Rewritten books
for him that's all at nine
foreign
[Music]
welcome to both all right Eurovision
fans either of you oh yeah no I knew it
I thought it was a lot of kid you I
thought it was a lottery yes I was like
where is the Eurovision in my bank
account and they're like show in the
world yeah you work of course you of
course you watch it
um it's the voting isn't it it's the
voting see if Britain can get in the
middle voting in the world possibly
outside the Pollock Bureau literally
um let's talk about gay actors this
bubbles around this story and people say
wokory doesn't exist listen to this
Netflix is Heartland star Aiden Mourinho
thinks he's not authentic for a straight
actor to play a gay character he happens
to be gay uh he plays the first major
lgbtq plus character in the Canadian
series okay fine a gay guy should play a
gay guys is now I tweeted back when I
saw this story all right then straight
people should play straight roles I mean
I have to yeah yeah doesn't it yeah or
we just assume actors could play any
role it is now I I understand where
actors come from if they feel
discriminated and they're not getting
lots of parts or anything why are the
parts are like me I'm not getting you
sometimes get from working class actors
too
but it's your ability to be on this
panel done no no I agree it's acting
when actors um you know perform in sort
of sex scenes right are they taking jobs
from prostitutes I mean that's the point
who's going to play Adolf Hitler in a
movie well yeah who's going to play a
mafioso boss what happens with The
Sopranos what happens with the West Wing
have you got to be a president of the
United States to play a president I mean
the whole thing once you go down this
Avenue of woke thinking as always
Insanity learns yeah I mean Scarlett
Johansson got in trouble for saying this
actually she had to backtrack and
apologize they all apologize I love
being an actress we had uh you know uh
Eddie Redman wasn't it who apologized
for playing a transgender person
but why is he apologizing he was great
and shot a light on transgender issue he
was but I don't think we always end up
in a lunatic position it's just it's a
discussion to make us more aware and
think about it that I think is not a bad
thing I think that's bizarre when you
talk about acting because surely all
that's the whole your entire profession
is played on being something that you're
not so why do we have to talk about this
thing this person must be hired because
you turn on Netflix and they have a
whole period you know series about
England back in you know the 19th
century and half the cast of black and
you're like you think that was what the
aristocracy was like yeah but if that
right that's Bridget and you're quite
right but by the way I don't care it's a
better I don't care but no if you're
going to be true to yourself yeah but
but I'm not sure it's meant to be a
doctor I've got to leave it there Keep
It Uncensored thank you back we'll do
more time tomorrow thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
sets out this five-point plan what has
it achieved so far nothing when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apology
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it